Senate Republicans are delivering on
their promise for open debate on
immigration it was part of the deal that
ended the first government shutdown this
year chief congressional correspondent
Mike Emanuel looks at where things are
headed up on the hill do we want really
tremendous border security but we have
to have Democrats support for daca and
they are starting that process today we
think there's a good chance of getting
doc had done if the Democrats are
serious and they actually want to do it
a hopeful tone from President Trump as
the Senate launches debate on the
difficult issue of immigration
today Republican senators Grassley corn
and Perdue Tillis Lankford cotton and
Ernst are rolling out an immigration
plan which reflects the president's
proposal we would address the young
people brought to this country illegally
by their parents fun border security
with a wall while ending so-called
chained migration and the Visa Lottery
today the top Senate leaders noted the
challenge ahead but insisted they can
reach a deal at every critical moment in
this country we've come together to do
what needed to be done to move the ball
down the field it won't be easy but
we're all going to try because of the
gravity of the issues at stake and
because we know that this week will be a
test of whether the Senate can steer the
ship of state through the stormiest of
waters now I believe it can the house is
another story key conservatives are
backing a proposal from Judiciary
Chairman Bob Goodlatte which would
provide dreamers with three-year
renewable permits to live and work in
the US but emphasizes border protection
and interior enforcement I say find an
accommodation for them but no amnesty we
cannot have individuals get in the queue
in front of individuals that have been
legally working through this process for
years
Ohio Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
says it reflects what American voters
want what they want is border security
first so build the border security wall
in the chain migration get rid of this
crazy visa lottery do things in a way
that make good comments and get
sanctuary city publicity policy get rid
of those do those things first
California House Democrat says her side
blew it it was a real mistake that we
didn't use the leverage we had in the
last spinning though we have a couple
opportunities coming up maybe one and I
think we need to continue to use that
and Congress needs to stay there until
we get this done the politics will be
tricky for house leadership
conservatives are unhappy after last
week's spending deal and will be eager
to fight on daca Brett micromanaged live
on Capitol Hill my thanks